[Music]
[Applause]
it's the first call of the day for
ambulance technician Dan and paramedic
Danny
it's all the way to an hourly man at the
minute who's got swelling and pain to
one of his arms following some Falls
morning
Edward's arm injury looks serious you've
done a number on that thing yeah he's
got one Advanced Parkinson's bless him
he fell two days ago but his wife
delayed calling an ambulance
[Music]
the intense pressure on the NHS and
advice on recent strike days put her off
don't say on the television
only call if there's a matter of life
and death no don't worry if you fall as
someone Falls over give us a call
however full the hospitals are patients
like Edward need to be seen
they persuade him to go to a e people
are a bit scared like to call ambulances
because they think they're going to be
stuck in the corridor for a long time or
in the back of the ambulance straight
into that train
very unusual
it's often a very different story this
winter there's some days where we sat
outside and maybe 10 15 ambulances sat
outside Hospital we've all got patients
on the back
and the next call a category one a
reminder of the need for ambulances to
be able to respond immediately yeah so
we've got an elderly lady
um
is through that she's having
a seizure or some description they
quickly established there's a problem
with the patient's heart ECGs are all
over the place to be honest with you he
couldn't use some kind of facing down
her heart rate is so low there's a
danger it could stop heart rate at the
minute is
2929 symptomatic they start treatment
and are calling ahead to the hospital in
Coventry five minutes to you mate you're
definitely want to increase this
she goes straight in for emergency
surgery to fit a pacemaker when you see
how quickly they have to move on a
serious call like that you can
understand the frustration and concern
on the days when they can't get to those
category one calls because they're
queuing outside hospitals this time they
were able to save the patient but at the
moment there are no guarantees when
things go on as they have been for the
last few weeks no things can't go on as
they are really
um
building the cardiac lady on a normal
kind of busy day we would normally see
that would be a massive delay and but
potentially resulted in somebody's life
have you ever known it to be like this
no never never something has got to give
the question is what with long delays
strikes and thousands of excess deaths
the the pressure on the NHS is
unprecedented and the route to recovery
far from Clear Becky Johnston Sky News
Coventry